what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch
the season two premiere of brooklyn nine
nine today thank you for being here if
you enjoy a reaction please go ahead and
hit the like button or dislike be honest
you can subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next brooklyn
nine-nine is up as usual full-length
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code or over at our patreon page
cover a whole bunch of shows over there
as well thanks to prepper for editing
this yep a man named prepper
weird dude
anyway
let's enjoy this
with a
laugh riot in the coming i can feel it
[Music]
it's me excuse me
hi what
angie marco you just got slapped with
the best life sentence there is
marriage
to angie and marco make us proud have a
son salute
what if they don't have a son
hey you're one of us now
you know how long i've been waiting for
one of you old men to kiss me oh no oh
no
oh no i gotta say out of the four you i
think vito's the best kiss
made man now
although the meatballs were a little dry
dried meatballs that's peralta's signal
let's
oh go did he mean that i sure as hell
hope so was it a slip of the tongue
nobody say anything how many times
i've missed us
[Music]
i'm so confused what's going on
you know he's he's undercover now that
he had to be fired from the force to
when was that a style
you you're a trickster he's here jake's
here let's do the prank but we don't
even acknowledge him when he comes in
okay
yeah good luck boyle
back in the nine-nine
[Applause]
oh my god late to perfection charles all
right fill me in tell me everything i
missed terry chipped his tooth and had a
lisp for a week
listen up stephen
i'm sorry did i say something amusing to
you hands to me you son of a [ __ ]
santiago wore the same outfit to work
one day
[Music]
yeah
can we talk in private for a second
i know we left things kind of weird you
know me saying that i liked you i'm
still with teddy
romantic styles
oh
good good cause i was gonna say i know
left things weird because i said that i
liked you but that was a mistake you
know i was nervous about going
undercover and i think i just kind of
freaked out and you were nearby so
i didn't mean it
but that's great good
what the hell
teddy oh come on another drill hello
my name is adelaide i like to report a
crime so we're just doing one of these
every day
oh you got it
yeah
terry
you pretty excited about jake being back
yeah it's like when i was a kid and my
grandma came home from the hospital only
better because jake's not unresponsive
nobody can ever know that we had sex all
right i have spent years cultivating a
reputation as someone who sleeps with
bike messengers
or better look i don't want people
finding out about it either i don't want
to be known as the office [ __ ] yeah well
jake's back and you tell him everything
no i don't
i got aroused last night watching a
nature documentary on bees it was fine
until they went inside the hive
oh you're right i'm gonna tell them so
much so much to unpack there
definitely won't be later than tomorrow
so pretty much today or tomorrow then
15 or 16 targets are in custody wait who
got away freddie miley already but
freddie's like the worst of all those
guys i should go back undercover see if
any of my contacts can tell me where he
is no they're looking for a rat and as a
former cop there's no way they're going
to trust you i guarantee you they do
the mafia once you joel together you're
bonded for life
sometimes things are just out of your
control
not good enough
oh
boyle
but you smell really bad that's my
cologne
welcome to the mafia
like mafia jake
when you were undercover did you like
have a mafia best friend i'm not jealous
i'm just wondering i don't know i guess
i did a bunch of jobs with a guy named
derek
great
great so we're going to the restaurant
what's my cover me and the mob oh i've
got the perfect thing the sun hat
[Laughter]
pick a fight with me and punch me in the
face no i could never hurt you jake well
you got to hit me somewhere i'm fine
it'll be the ball set no just hit me in
the face look if it's so hard imagine
i'm somebody you hate derek i barely
know
i think it would help if we knew why we
were doing these drugs because i ordered
you two
resume the drill timmy and do not do or
say anything that a seven-year-old boy
would not do or say feel free to consult
the script i've prepared okay but uh
it's a little stilted
oh no you should have the prospect of a
parentless existence
those lines were lifted verbatim from my
boyhood diary
[Music]
of course they were
my boyhood diary look i'm looking for
freddy you seen him it's funny a lot of
people are looking for that guy a lot of
cops especially
didn't used to be a cop jake
i'm just kidding man i know you were
saying piano man together
[Laughter]
i can't tell you where freddie but i can
tell you his girl bianca just called in
to have freddie's regular order
delivered to her address
well if it isn't jake peralta get out of
here boyle i know that we used to be
friends but that has changed all right
whoa wow now the balls
full derrick what the hell happened i i
was stressed about hitting you and my
mind disassociated from my body i don't
even know what i did oh well let me
remind you you punched me kicked me spat
on me
there's more where that came from i got
a real wet mouth
oh yeah
bianca lives here i'm gonna go in alone
if i need backup i will hit the clicky
button on my keys copy that time to get
back into character
clone me bro
okay here we go not the pace oh it
stings the cut yeah yep yeah that's over
what is wrong with me
okay keep going okay
oh yeah
this is boring happens not here sergeant
oh i won't build a lego house how about
we finish building this tower the
structure's done but we've barely
started on the landscaping i want to
build a spaceship
no
i worked so hard on that there were
stables these toys stop
okay
then i'll get you some better toys
timmy
you know bring back like a night stick
i'm jake i'm a friend of freddy's from
work i'm looking for him freddy actually
said i should come by here if i was ever
in trouble
well freddie was here but he left but
come on come on in so did he say where
he was heading or heard about you
peralta i know you were the rat get him
up get your hands up
there's the wallet and some keys nothing
strange about it okay this is just the
clicker for my car jake
of course
of course
oh crap my gun
[Music]
get it down all right don't shoot that's
how people get shot your weapon
all right bianca what do you know about
a guy named derrick charles ah
that's jurassic park don't timmy tough
now you're having fun sergeant
captain we were just uh jimmy was cranky
we just let him tire himself out okay
everybody else
okay
it's just kind of difficult because of
the deflating oh no turn on the puck i'm
very claustrophobic
i'm not gonna sell out freddy we're in
love come on he has a dozen mistresses
and six girlfriends freddy loved me he
implied that many times there's nobody
else okay yeah there is i just wish i
could remember who
so many people were sleeping with each
other it's kind of hard to keep track i
actually thought of a song that helps me
remember see it goes
and mario is doing it with theresa
theresa is doing it with paulie
freddy is cheating with bianca g
but also with her younger sister valerie
no oh yeah i saw them together that's
why it's in the song i knew it
i knew it
he's going to the tetoboro airport
because freddie is going to barbados
as everyone knows my spirit animal is
nature's greatest predator the wolf
but i committed a horrible sexual
blunder and i'm no longer wolf worthy
my spirit animal is now this
the naked mole rat
god's disgusting mistake
it's pretty ugly hey
only i get to talk about my spirit
animal that way you don't get to say
that come on amy
the squad's been stressed since these
drills started plus you ordered me to
act like a seven-year-old
seven-year-olds like to have fun that's
true when i was seven i used to sneak
into my father's office to see his
collection of antique globes
[Laughter]
there's gonna be a new commissioner of
the nypd
we're all gonna be under a microscope
and i want us to be prepared for
anything you should have just told us
that i was trying to shield you
do you know how much stress i've been
under lately my husband says he hasn't
seen me smiling weeks how much did you
smile before that constantly
[Laughter]
and not knowing what your bosses are up
to it's driving you a little crazy
you've used my logic against me well
played timmy well played thank you sir
look at that
you've helped me find my smile
never let it leave
no no again
damn it what do you think you're doing
jake peralta nypd i need you to shoot
down that plane
this man was on board he wasn't on that
plane that guy's plane left like an hour
ago great
that's fantastic i didn't let anyone
touch anything while you were gone and
that was a mistake i left food
everywhere this drawer is completely
full of maggots now
all right wanna get a drink nope i think
i'm just gonna stay here and stare into
the maggot drawer hey that's a good name
for a death metal song staring to the
maggot draw
you put away 15 high-ranking mafia guys
yeah and one of them got away it's a
disgrace you did everything you could i
mean sometimes there's stuff you just
can't control why does everyone keep
saying that to me you should be proud
i think i like this new forthright and
confident version of charles
let's go get that drink because there's
a surprise party and it's my job to get
you to the bar what
i mean it's my job to get someone to the
bar for your surprise party
[Laughter]
surprise
[Music]
i am floored by this charles you tricked
me boyle told you didn't he without any
prompting
welcome
[Laughter]
i want him to say stuff
speech for jake speech for jake go very
well
uh your six-month absence was noted yes
there's a two drink maximum per person
here you guys it is non-transferable
valet parking is not included it's a
solid protocol
i'm very proud of you peralta we missed
you ah oh ruined it
[Laughter]
what is this champagne mixed with 30
year old scotch and top shelf tequila
captain said a two drink max but he did
not set a price limit smort hmm
everyone's paying their attention oh god
it's horrible yeah i shouldn't have
added the olive juice ew
the thing i said you before i went
undercover about how i wish something
had happened between us romantically
that wasn't nothing that was real
oh no dude i know that you're with teddy
i'm not trying to change that and i get
there stuff i can't control but this
morning i told you that i didn't mean
any of it and that was a lie
i just don't want to hold anything back
well thank you for saying that just as
long as we're clear that i'm with
someone and nothing is going to happen
unless someone nothing's going to happen
name your sex tape
he's back
neat sweater ugh did you tell jake yet i
need to what
i had tons of chances to tell them about
what happened six months ago and i
didn't why not i didn't want to hurt
your feelings no
sounds like our nightmare is finally
over
she has a smile on her face
what is that jennifer jason lee and the
thumbnail for the next one
couldn't be we'll have to find out next
week there's no way to verify it
especially when the episode starts
immediately
what did you think
i thought that was a delight it's so
nice to be back with all my old friends
again after exactly one week
of not actually being away from them for
that long but uh yeah i mean it seemed
like they hadn't skipped a beat really
definitely carrying on threads from the
previous episode you know bit cereal to
start things off like cereal that's
right man it's good stuff it's the
breakfast of champions really like mafia
jake peralta i think that's a very just
fun place to follow him around in
uh him and charles ain't skipping a beat
hilarious terry moments across the
episode
good breakdown you got going thanks man
thanks
tune in next week
but uh no i thought this was super fun
and a very confident season to premiere
what did you think oh it had a stark
cacophony of percolating tension that's
right that's right it was a tone poem
of comedic ambiance
let's just say the most used words john
used for the dark shows that we watched
yes
star cacophony of i was trying to build
a deliberate tension
oppressive
dread fueled percolating
uh yeah no it was a delightful episode
it was absolutely delightful
do people review comedy shows every week
i don't know i mean 20 minutes it comes
a hard format to be like
cutting edge criticism weekly
daily i don't think we've once had
cutting-edge criticism in all these
years
ah you know maybe on certain things but
maybe not on 20-minute comedy i
constantly hear other people do reviews
of the same things we cover i'm like ah
they said it better than i could have
you never know though other people
perceive it differently maybe somebody
checked out a real rejects video once
upon a time was like damn the way that
greg broke that down that's my favorite
way anybody's articulated that i feel
like someone finally understands what
i've been feeling about such and such a
thing yeah these guys are a good preview
before i listen to mr sunday movies
since they're uploading later that's
right we are mr sunday
your visitor sunday i'm nick mason this
is perfect
yeah
okay so uh yeah i mean um
i think uh
i think uh jake and amy um eventually
they got to get together right it's like
seems like it's inevitable no the movie
after the show has ended that's when
they finally get together no show's
already even gone through a resurrection
they're not going to get a movie kind of
fair enough that's right yeah we're on
to season nine now it's it already was
temporarily canceled
yeah they're back on track okay
um so yeah that uh uh
wha wha why why were they what were they
preparing i didn't quite get why the the
the antics with playing um
annoying victims
was coming into the fold here with the
commissioner i i'm i'm a little bit lost
there oh is jennifer jason lee the
a great man commissioner would be a
great chance for us they put her in the
thumbnail what am i supposed to do guys
pops up right here on our wrap a chance
for a very notable guest star and a good
subversion of expectations because i'm
sure everybody's expecting the
commissioner to be some heavy uh male
veteran actor but yeah no that would
make a lot of sense i was expecting i
could have gone
i could have gone either or and not one
of my thoughts would have i was
expecting dakota fan
yeah that's what i was gonna say all
right so uh yeah explain it to me again
uh i mean yeah
what i took from that is just yeah
there's a new commissioner coming in and
we gotta be on top of it so me holt i
gotta make sure that everyone's prepared
for any possible
circumstance whip everybody into shape i
didn't see i i didn't glean like a very
specific leg here's what each of these
is for it just sort of seemed like yeah
the commissioner's gonna come and if
we're not like ship shaped they're gonna
be pissed
how did they sneak a bounce house onto
the roof that's a great excellent
question i couldn't i could not tell you
that
anywhere near there really yeah they
have one in evidence
maybe maybe it was full of drugs at one
point there's a missing scene this
episode was rushed well that's true lack
of character development that's going to
be at least double the length big plot
hole yeah it seemed like they just
couldn't wait to get this episode over
with
on the episode
to the cliffhanger yeah that's right
so i i take it that this uh the whole
thing with mafia guys coming back into
the fold it's gotta i mean like we gotta
meet i was trying to see if the picture
they held up with a guy was some notable
comedian but i couldn't tell but i i
would have to imagine that yeah that
thread's got to come back because it's
going to haunt andy say it's going to
haunt peralta
one guy got away so yeah yeah
well i also
really love
gina
and boyle i think that's a great duo
because
i think
they can i think
their
idiosyncrasies can quite complement each
other
dude that was smooth
that was the job intellectual right
don't try to draw attention to
to the cutting board
no continue discussing their
idiosyncrasies and how they complement
and contract let me just try to remember
what idiosyncrasies means for like five
seconds first of course yeah
you know
obviously i have
pauses in here to see if john nods or
goes
and so do i that's true and i guess
those pauses of i have an idea or one of
my idiosyncrasies
perhaps
uh yeah what were we talking about
the
uh union of or or the con the comedic
chemistry between gina and boyle
right
yes that is good and they can
cough about each other
very well yeah and
um i think they've set themselves up for
more um classic sitcom stuff which is
romantic
entanglements but the cop things are the
things i like the most still i really
love the
the whole thing with the commissioner oh
yeah oh that seems like the bread of
butter and then you know these
relationships not that they're bad and
not that you know we won't fall in love
with any you know pairing of characters
but that feels more like requisite like
hey we gotta have some romance right you
know who plays rosa steve stephanie
beatrice yeah
dude
i got
i got an affinity for her
dude all of the best words today
she i don't know what it is about her
mm-hmm
it's like oh she's got a husband and we
gotta kill him and i'm supposed to get
married too yeah oh wow look at this
bald [ __ ] yeah yeah she wouldn't she
wouldn't want a guy with your luscious
curls she's all about babies
yes that's what's up
damon lindelof lost writer
who is this guy
dude it's it's the one time where
hollywood's just like stephanie
beatrice's husband and you're like who
is that what's his name give him a name
then she has a she's pregnant yeah man
you gotta just you gotta break up this
brad haas
let's see this what's up brad hoff
freaking [ __ ] is
teddy and bruh she already had the kid
oh man dude we gotta go and and i don't
know we gotta figure something out for
you this is heartbreaking
well i don't care about him anymore he's
my teddy
yeah
yeah i don't blame you that's a
reasonable response
uh yeah that is uh that was some good
stuff man yeah i i agree the
pairing him and gina off it's like you
know there's that whoa will they
eventually won't they with rosa but i
feel like because gina is like just as
hard as rosa in a lot of ways but also a
lot goofier like there's a whole other
chemistry that unlocks between her like
i feel like the train of just hijinks
can go longer between gina and charles
than gina and rosa if that makes and i
was really i was really glad that jake
also was honest with amy uh at the end
because i didn't want to repeat this too
much
and like live in the
veneer of it all of like how he's like
you know that's right i [ __ ] said
another word
so dear
[Laughter]
guys keep your dictionary apps open from
now on in these reviews yeah that's
right i'll forget with all these you're
gonna be like the architect over here
the anomaly of the placement of the
comedic structures
the systematic comedic elements the
systematic subversion of expectations
this is
[Laughter]
but yeah getting past the whole like
facade that he puts up of all that you
know uh it was like okay we're gonna
redo all this again where he's able to
throw myself back into the case and try
to escape with this and it's like it
makes sense that he would kind of
slingshot himself in into that realm
again but
to come to terms right at the top and
just be like hey look still like you uh
i know nothing's going to happen but
it's got to be honest i i was i was
really appreciative of that because i
was like we can't drag this beat out
never did it all through season one okay
we can't drag this out somewhere yeah
at least acknowledge or evolve it or do
something to clue us in that this isn't
going to just be the same repetitive
meat yeah but overall another solid
solid episode
um
very much enjoyed it put me in a good
mood uh yeah we'll um
we'll catch you guys soon
for another cacophonous stark
bleak
desolate
yes
forelorn for boating yes
oppressive
sheen
she and the yeah machine
uh vernier
no you used veneer already damn i'm not
as brilliant as you are no no
oh no
still trying to learn percolating i'll
see you guys
you